tonight a very concerning story every
parent needs to really pay attention to
a ccsd
sub teacher arrested accused of luring
children for sex
online take a look at this this is eric
huey taken into custody on march
3rd investigators believe there may be
more victims
sasha loftus combed through his
background an arrest report and joins us
now with more details sasha
denise and brian huey was well known as
an educator here in southern nevada
and worked as a long-term substitute who
taught english at western high school
he's now facing multiple charges
including soliciting a child
for prostitution this is eric huey
an accused child predator who was well
known across
las vegas
this video from 2018 shows hughes
speaking out at a community meeting
he worked as a substitute teacher here
at western high school
and a mentor for at-risk kids at
acceleration academy
the arrest report released wednesday
says huey offered to pay
100 dollars to have sex with a person
online
who he reportedly thought was 15 years
old
that person was actually a police
officer
working as part of a multi-agency effort
in which 14 people were arrested for
trying to alert children online
this is our home this is our community
i'm concerned about
the welfare of not only my children but
the children
of others who go to schools and
in the city not long before this
interview where huey was condemning
violence in north las vegas
ccsd and my vegas magazine also
recognized him as one of the top
100 men of the year in 2016. in a
recorded interview
after his arrest huey reportedly told
police
i know better and i'm sorry but officers
believe
he may have had other victims and are
asking anyone affected
to come forward anyone who may have been
a victim
of eric huey or know anyone with any
information
related to additional crimes is asked to
call north las vegas police you see the
number on your screen
702-633-1773
now we have reached out to ccsd and
acceleration academy
but have not yet heard back reporting
live in the newsroom tonight sasha
loftis
8 news now